[Musique]
qui est le père d'anakin voici l'une des
questions les plus posées sur l'univers
de star wars avant de devenir le célèbre
terrible seigneur sith dark vador année
qui n'était un jedi qui encore
auparavant n'étaient simplement qu'un
esclave
l'histoire nous raconte que la mère
d'anna kinsch me serait tombée enceinte
miraculeusement alors qu elle ne
fréquentait aucun homme en grandissant
anakin développe un don pour la
mécanique et la venue de quoi rigole
jean nous montrera que le jeune garçon
possède également un don pour la force
avec un taux de midi clos rien supérieur
même à celui de maître yoda le plus
grand jedi de son erp et dirigeants de
l'orb la saga ne tardera pas nous
évoquer l'éventuelle possibilité
khanaqinne soit un élu de la force
ramenant l'equilibre en détruisant les
sites mais les jedi comprennent danse
beaucoup spéculent que l'udc serait le
véritable élus cependant c'est bien à
keane qui tua dark sidious le dernier
site de l'épopée avec vador qui n'est
autre khanaqinne lui même il a aussi tué
de nombreux jedi et tous les apprentis
de l'ordre mais revenons au fait qui est
le père d'anne hacking est bien de
nombreuses théories existe mais une
seule parviens à me convaincre et je
souhaite vous la partagez
parlons du seigneur sith darth plagueis
lesage il dit que darth plagueis était
si puissant qu'il pouvait influer sur
les midis clos rien et donc créer la vie
posséder une telle connaissance de la
force qu'il pouvait maintenir des
personnes en vie ou bien en ranimer
cependant ces manipulations sur la force
et donc les midis clos rien son
contraire à la nature la vie et la mort
font partie de celles ci et s'auto
régulent depuis des générations la
nature trouve toujours son chemin et la
force a donc créé anakin skywalker et
lui qui doit ramener l'équilibré dans la
force mais deux cas de figure sont
possibles soit la force a créé anakin
pour ramener l'équilibré
d'où la prophétie ou bien un akin serait
une erreur nick d'arcy guise et qu'il
aurait créé et le jeune esclave durant
ces manipulations sans le vouloir mais
je penche plutôt dans le premier cas de
figure pour moi c'est une évidence
darse l'église possède un rapport avec
la naissance d'anakin tout est lié
une prophétie qui parle d'un élu
ramenant l'equilibre dans la force
perturbé par les manipulations du
seigneur les guides
entre autres l'entraînement de nombreux
jedi à cause de l'ordre la nature soit
la force a décidé de punir les sites et
les jedi à cause de la perturbation créé
fortement influencé par les
manipulations de pelé guise qui avait
pour simple but de vaincre la mort
qu'en pensez vous n'hésitez pas à me
dire votre avis dans les commentaires
on se retrouve bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo c'était un argot rock que le liner
soit à vue
[Musique]